As we mentioned
Democrats want a shocking victory in the deepest red state in America last night defeating Republican
Roy Moore in the Senate race in Alabama and delivering a stunning blow to both Steve Bannon and president Trump for more on this
It's time for a closer look
Democrats haven't had much to celebrate since last year's election
And they could hardly contain themselves last night as evidenced by the victory rally at doug jones
Headquarter the crowd there was so excited that c-span caught the DJ playing jones off the stage with teach me how to dougie
First thing
No one ever teach Doug Jones how to dougie?
That is not for him
Second thing to whoever was smoking weed and watching a lecture results safe to say that was the best moment of your life
Because that was definitely the most beat ever played on c-span at least not since Bernie Sanders released his rap album under the name
Sean don't own any combs of
Course one big question after the results came in was Howard Donald Trump react and surprisingly he seemed to strike a conciliatory tone
President Trump just tweeted minutes ago saying congratulations
To Doug Jones on a hard-fought victory the write-in votes played a very big factor
but a win is a win the people of Alabama are great and the
Republicans will have another shot at this seat in a very short period of time it never ends
There is no way Donald Trump wrote that tweet
He probably went to the bathroom and forgot his phone and someone else said this is our chance write something decent
How much time until he's back, and they said well he had two Big Macs to fillet a fish in a milkshake
So I don't know an hour
Three minutes, there's no way of knowing what that does to a human body
But hey how bad is this for Trump really?
It's not like he pulled out all the stops and states his agenda his reputation and his presidency
I'm backing an accused child molester thinking there was no way he could lose in the deepest red state in America right the president
United States has officially endorsed one more for Senate President Trump is jumping with both feet for more president Trump
Has just recorded a last-minute
Robo call for Roy Moore President Trump tweeted today that quote the people of Alabama will do the right thing unquote and vote for Republican
Roy Moore according to the GOP candidates campaign the president talked to more over the phone and cheered go get him Roy
I think he's gonna do very well
We don't want to have a liberal Democrat in Alabama
We don't need a liberal person in there a Democrat so get out and vote for Roy Moore
Well, how does he say it like that?
He's pronouncing Roy Moore his name like he's playing it on a tuba get out and vote but would
Make America great again
Can we hear that one more time
Now the closing weeks
The closing weeks of this campaign tell us a lot about how this happened with the allegations looming over and more essentially
disappeared from the campaign trail spending long stretches out of the spotlight
Avoiding rallies and interviews and his extreme views were difficult for his surrogates to defend
For example Moore had said that Muslims should be barred from serving in Congress on Tuesday
CNN's Jake Tapper asked more campaign spokesman Ted Crockett to explain that view and let's just say it did not go well
Judge Moore has also said that he doesn't think a Muslim member of Congress should be allowed to be in Congress
Why?
Under what under what because you have to swear on the Bible
You and you when you are before I had to do it. I'm an elected official three terms
I had to swear on a Bible you have to swear on a Bible to be an elected official in the United States of America
He alleges that a Muslim cannot do that ethically swearing on the Bible
You don't actually have to swear on a Christian Bible you can swear on anything really
I don't know if you knew that you can swear on Jewish Bible
Three times I'm sure I'm sure you've picked a Bible
But the law is not that you have to swear on a Christian Bible. That is not the law
You don't know that
All right Ted Crockett
I don't know
I know that Donald Trump did it when he when we made him president because he's Christian and he picked it look at him
He looks like the last hole at a miniature golf course
war eventually
Resurfaced on Monday night at a rally designed to appeal the Trump voters by borrowing one of Trump slogans drained the swamp they even went
so far as to decorate the venue in the spirit of that slogan this event has been promoted as the drain the swamp rally and
If you can see the signage behind me
That's the message this
Campaign wants to resonate with voters who come here tonight as they walk past the literal swamp this campaign is built with fake
Alligators and foliage so give it a choice the accused sexual predator said we should do it like a prom theme?
Dress it up like a prom theme
Now you think in the closing hours of the campaign more would have wanted to avoid any mention of the child
Molestation accusations against him and yet one of the introductory speakers at the rally a friend who served with more in Vietnam
Told a bizarre story about how they and a third guy ended up at a brothel with young girls
That's your argument
He can't be a child molester because one time he didn't
Cool, I remember one game where AJ had a hundred and forty rushing yards three receptions and no murders
But more of course had a key backer who stood by him former White House chief strategist Steve
Bannon Bannon who has cultivated the myth that he's some sort of political strategic genius was an early in vocal Moore supporter
But these results have once again deflated Bannon self-styled
Reputation as a political mastermind because Bannon made mistake after mistake
Just take his comments from Monday's rally in which ban in the former goldman sachs trader who's lived in, Virginia and California
Went out of his way to brag about the elite schools. He went to while responding to MSNBC host joe scarborough
So there you go Bannon says Scarborough went to a much crappier school than he did
So where did Scarborough go to school anyway Joe Scarborough went to the University of Alabama?
How stupid do you have to be to insult the University of Alabama in Alabama?
Who do you think they're gonna support roll tide or someone who looks like he literally rolled up in the tide of?
Course Moore himself didn't have much to say in the closing weeks of the campaign
But he did seem to be making a statement by defiantly riding to the polls yesterday on his horse to cast his ballot
Is it just me or does it look like even his horse is trying to get away from him
Can we hear what the horse is saying?
Get off me you creep
No
This race was obviously unique in many ways
But let's not act like Moore was some sort of aberration who was isolated from the rest of the GOP
He was supported of course by the president
It was the leader of the Republican Party and the Republican National Committee, and yet some Republicans were so ashamed
They couldn't even bring themselves to say more his name like Jeff Sessions an Alabama resident, who?
Vacated the Senate seat to become Attorney General Sessions was asked yesterday who he voted for and did everything he could to avoid
answering the question I voted absentee yes, and I
value the sanctity of the ballot, and I would say
The people of Alabama are good and decent and wonderful people I've been proud to serve for 20 years in the Senate
And they'll make the right decision I'm sure I haven't seen Cession sweat that much since every time he's testified before Congress
Come on, mr.. Attorney-general who did you vote for I don't recall?
of course
Moore's message was a muddled mix of lawless theocracy and cultural grievances and in the end that message was rejected
But this victory is owed primarily to black voters and especially black women who came out in huge numbers and voted overwhelmingly
To save the country from the nightmare of a demagogue and accused child molester serving in the Senate
Meanwhile Republicans are left to explain why a party that nominated almost elected such a man should ever be trusted again Ted Crockett
Do you have anything to say about?
There's been a closer look